competitive shooters are serious
business
they depict epic battles between
modern-day soldiers and insurgents in
war-torn cities or conflicts between
space marines and aliens on distant
worlds or skirmishes between
battle-hardened men and subterranean
creatures who try to slice each other to
bits with rifle mounted chainsaws
there's nothing wrong with any of that
but there's also no reason why the
broadly appealing mechanics of
multiplayer shooters always need to be
married to such grim scenarios that's
what makes plants vs. zombies garden
warfare so enticing mechanically it's
solid if unsurprising it distinguishes
itself from other shooters not through
its gameplay but by successfully
counting familiar shooter action in the
bright and playful world of the plants
vs. zombies games still the package
feels a bit thin even at the $40 asking
price that the game carries on the Xbox
one garden warfare is strictly a
team-based multiplayer game each mode
has you siding with either the plants or
the zombies as the age-old ERV
four-year-old conflict between them
rages on as in so many competitive
shooters gameplay is class-based there
are four basic units on each side among
the plants there's the well-rounded pea
shooter whose pea cannon does Splash
Damage and there's the sunflower whose
heal beam can give allies the extra
vitality they need to survive a shootout
among others the zombie army includes
the engineer who can call in a drone to
attack enemies from the air and rain
down explosive traffic cone-shaped death
on those pesky plants they've also got
the all-star a zombie and football getup
who's pigskin shooting cannon takes a
second to spin up but does lots of
damage once it gets going the game does
a good job of balancing out the
abilities on each side the Chomper can
burrow underground get under an enemy
and first forced to swallow him whole a
wonderfully satisfying move to pull off
but nearby zombie engineers can use
their sonic grenades to stun all nearby
enemies forcing burrowed chompers out of
the ground in the
yes and the game makes defensive
abilities just as important as offensive
ones the cactuses potato mines can
fortify a location against those zombies
who are too reckless to look where
they're going and the all-stars dummy
shields can absorb enemy fire in garden
warfare as in most of the better
competitive shooters on the market these
days you're not always focused just on
killing members of the other team you're
trying to use a variety of abilities at
your disposal can most effectively
support your team in team vanquish games
the best way to support your team is in
fact to kill members of the other team
this playlist hits teams of up to 12
against each other in a race 250 kills
and encourages you to revive fallen
teammates which subtracts the point the
opposing team earned for killing your
buddy from their tally more dynamic are
the battles of the gardens and
graveyards playlist and which plants
work together to prevent zombies from
capturing key points on the map only one
point is contested at any time so
battles for those points are heated and
if the zombies succeed in putting the
plants back to the last battleground on
a map there's an enjoyable endgame goal
that the undead path to accomplish on
one map zombies launched themselves
through a cannon to an island to assault
the mega flower and on another they have
to assault crazy Dave's mansion which is
defended by cannons that launched a
massive wall nuts that roll down the
driveway like bowling balls there's also
the cooperative garden ops game pipe in
which four players defend the garden
from waves of ai-controlled zombies if
you survive all the waves there's a left
for dead style escape attempt which some
players may survive while others don't
making for some exciting and desperate
final moments but the AI zombie boards
aren't as clever or as enjoyable to mow
down as player controlled opponents so
garden ops lacks the liveliness of the
competitive mode there are tons of
unlockables in garden warfare everything
from accessories like lipstick for your
sunflower to character variations like
the dapper agent P who sacrifices the
standard pea shooters Splash Damage for
a damage bonus on critical hits
but while the unlockable fit right in
with the whimsical spirit of the plants
versus
these franchise you're left feeling like
garden warfare needed a little something
more to make it a meal rather than a
side salad still it's that rare shooter
whose world and characters might
actually put a smile on your face making
it a refreshing entry in a genre that
usually takes itself really seriously